Hola Qué tal Buenas noches dijo muchas
cosas en su discurso fue un discurso
largo de dos horas más de 14.000
palabras la transcripción del discurso y
su señalamiento muy fuerte hacia la
Corte Suprema de Justicia de la nación
miembros de la corte estaban presentes
en el recinto cuando lo hizo la criticó
entre otras cosas por por su rol en lo
que es el consejo de la magistratura que
es el órgano que se encarga entre otras
cosas de nombrar a jueces a magistrados
en el país y que en este momento Está
trabado su funcionamiento y ese es uno
de los ejemplos que da Alberto Fernández
de los problemas que tiene la justicia
en Argentina un desafío que él no pudo
resolver se lo había planteado el inicio
de su mandato tratar de impulsar una
reforma en el sector judicial algo que
hacia el final de su mandato estamos
viendo que no ocurrió natalio en
términos de economía el presidente
aprovechó para hablar del crecimiento
económico de Argentina pero también dijo
que la alta inflación es producto de la
desorganización que más dijo sobre este
tema
es interesante el presidente Alberto
Fernández se fue muy fuerte con una
estrategia que ya lleva adelante la casa
rosada hace unas semanas que es contra
toda la sensación generalizada que hay
en el país y todo todos los mensajes
constantes de las dificultades que
existen en el plano económico que son
absolutamente reales Sobre todo como
decías impulsadas por la profunda
inflación que está en torno al 100%
anual en este momento la casa rosada
tiene esta estrategia de mostrar datos
que son positivos por ejemplo incremento
en el número de asalariados incremento
en la inversión incremento en el
producto bruto son todas cifras que dan
vueltas y que ellos explican y dicen que
respaldan una gestión que es mejor que
lo que dice la oposición y lo que dice
muchos sectores dentro de la sociedad
pero lo cierto Es que la inflación Sigue
estando ahí y la inflación hasta que no
sea controlada termina muchas veces en
la experiencia cotidiana de los
argentinos dando por tierra con todas
estas otras argumentos positivos que
trata de llevar adelante y Mostrar el
presidente en su discurso natalio
rápidamente para el cierre que otros
puntos fueron destacados en este
discurso
bueno hizo referencia a malvinas hizo
sobre todo referencia a los 40 años de
la Democracia que se cumplen este año
hizo referencia a temas de Derechos
Humanos que son muy importantes y lo que
no hizo referencia hacia la posibilidad
de su candidatura la reelección que es
algo que todavía no está definido